What could be the cause of childhood asthma? What do you recommend for a child with seasonal allergy asthma flare-ups?
So asthma and childhood asthma is becoming more and more frequent even adult onset or adolescent onset asthma
person who might be in their 20s 30s 40s who's never had history of asthma
before their life is now
developing
Symptoms of asthma. So what in the world have never had asthma before now? I have shortness of breath when I start to work out or exercise exercise
adduced asthma
So the number one causes of asthma are toxicity issues
It can be a toxicity from a chemical toxicity from the environment which were being sprayed in our environment with everything from glyphosate from
farms to
Things over head in the airways were being polluted every which way we could possibly think
the food sensitivities read and the dies in foods are very common issue with asthma
So that's another toxicity issue when it's toxins that are consumed
Histamine can be an issue with asthma looking at that person's genes their HNMT genes their ability to get rid of histamine
In their tissues that can be an issue with asthma
Chronic lung infections can be an issue with asthma, but with childhood asthma many times if the child was not
invaccinated
So they didn't receive those toxins. It can be food sensitivities. So dairy and gluten are often common issues with asthma
with children
Less than six years old we don't typically recommend doing food sensitivity testing
We recommend doing a food elimination diet. So try doing you know eliminating the most common foods
That would cause an increase in inflammation in the lungs and the airways and in the tissues and that would be
started off would be dairy
gluten
the gluten cross-reacted foods and
and
egg soy
I would get rid of dyes red dye green dye blue dye all the dyes in different foods just try to clean up the environment
Another common issue with childhood asthma can be fire retardants in clothing
Babies clothing I think from a legal perspective anything that you're gonna buy from you know the department store or something like that
It's gonna have fire retardants in the material and it doesn't just
Wash out so getting organic cotton. I know it can be expensive to make these changes
But it can really save a person's life long term
So clean it out the person's diet cleaning your house as far as what you're using for detergents what you're using for soaps
What you're using for cleaning products
Trying to have a clean environment
You know, it's hard because there's fire retardants in your furniture you buy a new couch
There's fire retardants in it new chair. There's fire retardants in your carpeting
So it's very difficult to try to get rid of this stuff because it's everywhere
So it can be it can be an expensive endeavor maybe just you know do certain groups at a time to try to see if that can calm down
If the child is old enough to eat that say there are there two three-year-old or higher
Using anti-histamine type nutrition. We have a
Product called clear hiss junior. That is a chewable quite tasty
And natural into histamines got corseted and some things in it that can be good for kids
If the child is older it can swallow pills using some anti-histamines
As far as from a natural perspective, we have multiple different natural
Pills capsule form that you have to swallow certainly could open those things up and put them in a smoothie as well
Clean up the child's diet is gonna be a big thing though